what's up rejects Greg over here Tony
Gill right here Tony Gill he's starting
up a gaming channel
he's been editing and he's experimenting
a lot to keep a look out for that anyway
nothing to do with gaming the fate of
the Furious trailer just dropped yes
baby the Furious here let's see uh some
binge I feel like the rock is being way
more promoted than Vin Diesel for this
movie sorry to become the rocks it's
certainly become the Rock's freshest
people getting him the jobs I'm
basically you know the one running this
[ __ ] bait
aloneness these guys are taking this
personal you were only supposed to
create a diversion Roman that was
complete destruction you want for me
a Roman Pearce man what'd I do wrong -
what face mm with their mum people say
just the beers on me thought it was a
cop candles like you would you ever
think you'd betray your family the way
you did today
Dominic Toretto just turned on us Oh
well-well see look at that huh
I don't know why he's doing this that
wasn't dumb no it's a twin I took care
ISM now she's working with your guy
interesting I think I found like food
this should be interesting
oh [ __ ] oh damn I love this franchise
yes yes god damn which is why you gonna
need a little help yeah the rock like a
Cherokee drop oh nice damn Oh
Dumbo thin there damn all them together
you guys are gonna work together
surprise interesting whoa I've been
waiting for this we got a tank
let's roll
now I don't know the old Dom is in there
I don't give a damn god yeah the Deaf
count in this movie gyms there we go
booty you remember that part
wonderful fungus coffee no man
[Music]
I owe too much you're gonna turn your
back on family
oh hello oh wow
well I what a [ __ ] that was so far off
from what I could have ever expected for
this movie to be like that was crazier
the annihilation count in that trailer
just from the opening with him and it's
with [ __ ] rainbow going through the
submarine in the ice first off they're
just straight up being a Marvel movie
with it is now like they're destroying a
bunch of cars now they're fighting
against each other this is some civil
war with us today yeah I'm just [ __ ]
ridiculous right Oh being kind of like
the bad guy for this movie cuz obviously
there's something going on where
otherwise we just killed these guys if
he was really evil you know what again
would have found a way just a murder of
these dudes I feel like they take it way
back to the first one where he was
actually the bad guy in it yeah there
might be that yeah that's like now he's
like he's the bad guy again it's always
been about family kind of a kind of a
family family so how the father of the
families is going after the college it
uh it's the first time where I feel like
the family quote of The Fast and Furious
which I've always thought is so cheesy
and ridiculous yeah
actually is applicable for this movie I
could see how this feels like a family
being torn apart because instead of like
that cheesy asti were a family that that
thing like now I feel like the family
thing works for this one well just from
like the difference of them coming from
like street racing to doing crazy
missions these characters went from
being just regular people to know their
secret engine yeah they are pretty much
secret agents it's like oh now one
secret agent is gonna go to the other
team and it's just like forces against
each other it's the soul yeah it's a
wild that it's like Don's not the one
running it anymore for the rock now to
think about like how they barely use the
rock in the last one yeah like he was
barely in that one he's like the hero in
this one he's like the lead carry he's
definitely like the leader now that like
for this force that well yeah he's the
second toughest guy to replacement
kneazle to be the father
the family have to I wonder if they're
gonna deal with that like are they gonna
be able to trust Dwayne Johnson will
they go that deep were their characters
where can we really feel led by Dwayne
Johnson on this one Jason Statham's
character probably to really join their
forces because he wants to take out dawn
- so yeah exactly
cuz I was like how they're just gonna be
like hey just be on our team now yeah
maybe they just used exactly hotline but
um and the interaction is I think with
Jason Statham and Dwayne Johnson are
gonna be [ __ ] awesome because there
was barely any of that and like I was
excited when I thought they were gonna
fight again in the prison goes like yes
give us another Dwayne versus Statham is
like the younger version of Expendables
now where it's like oh I happy they
don't have all the old character they of
all the new action characters all up in
this movie they're getting a lot of
action characters like more and more
than going to the daddies do the sets
pieces have just gotten insanely more
ridiculous like that scene when they're
all like they have the wires connected
to Dom's car that part was crazy with
the part that they were like basically
using the machine gonna get innocence in
this for ya people it look like the
college crazy cuz it LOI doesn't like
they can't all be bad people that he's
shooting yeah there's got to be a lot of
innocent lives in her that's a high def
con in this trailer even with the like
wrecking ball look like they killed some
agents yeah so that's like American
people she's yeah well this is like
without book he's like there was just a
little bit of blood in sort of this
shots are our greatest may go like oh
you know that's a screech other yeah
yeah it's just fun there's no karate
yeah I wonder how that prison fight
scenes gonna go down like oh man because
we're Jason Statham was like doing
parkour in the prison there in the snow
and the ice somewhere all over the
[ __ ] planet in this submarine this is
like perfect time I knew they were gonna
be coming through here for my submarine
it doesn't treat me because obviously
dominic toretto is not going to be just
pure bad or pure evil there's something
going on where he has to do this
treacherous things in order to fulfill
whatever Charlize Theron is holding over
him its collateral on the rent so I'm
really wondering who Charlize Theron
characters and I think they're promoting
her just right because the first time we
got a villain that we could get excited
about was when Jason Statham was the
villain
yes we were like alright who's Jason
Statham and it showed a lot of him in
the trailer you don't really see a lot
of Charlize Theron in this trailer it's
more like making you go who exactly is
she what does she have on dominic
toretto that's allowing her to
manipulate and force him to do what she
wants him to do damn she still looks
[ __ ] fine doesn't she like there has
always been so [ __ ] hot to stream
making out with Vin Diesel right in her
oh damn
because at first I was like ah too much
too much showing that they're
infiltrating their right wing but then
when they had that moment I was like oh
this is personal
ever since Fast Five this has been one
of the most fun franchises you could
ever have gone to in the theaters and I
feel like this is a great way to take it
in another direction but just succeed
Dominic Toretto most of them I'm sure
don't want to kill him they just want to
capture him and be like what the [ __ ] is
going on like you said Jason Statham is
probably like if I get my first like
this chance I'm gonna kill him oh study
we could get one little side note about
like being that thing I look like it's
starting to look like a manager's movies
and stuff where it's like action-packed
isn't it funny that like Vin Diesel has
crashed his body in my car crashes and
like flown across it like yeah to catch
oh it's a superhero now Jesus basically
a super superhero I feel like he's these
guys dickly Colossus like it doesn't get
hurt at all you guys survived everything
two cars and he's all like let's go we
got to get out of here this movie looks
amazing the cars like the destruction
it's just they always try to top
themselves for holy [ __ ]
and I could definitely see why they got
the director of the Italian Job to
specifically do this I really do get
that press and this is cool because I
did the town job had Jason Statham and
Charlize they're in there and now he's
got both of these guys in here too it's
gonna be [ __ ] awesome this looks
really crazy
this looks like it's traveling the world
and it's like batshit nuts and I'm
actually rather intrigued by the plot
like I'm actually interested in more
than just the set pieces I'm like I kind
of want to see the plot I really want to
see how this unfolds all right rejects
or near the channel subscribe today get
accepted at tree easy on Instagram is
Tony Gill when his gaming channel comes
out we'll let you know
shoutout to Jesus Jesus like Jesus in
the Fast and the Furious movies I mean
that would be a character whose team
would be be now you call yourself a
family but you're all criminals he's the
main villain it's about them having to
drive their cars like Dominic Toretto
gets sent to hell Jesus put him there
why would Jesus do that to me the devil
though shout out to Satan he's got the
best ride he can make his tires flame oh
yeah yeah that should be the next best
bury they take on Satan basically
playing ghostwriter